hey everyone I'm Billy and I have been a
professional clown for the last 10 years
but back here behind me I've got a
couple of Impostors so I'm gonna be
drilling them figuring out who's the
real deal and who's just yanking my
rubber chicken all right let's get
started shall we
if you wouldn't mind everybody please
raise your left foot you right over here
won't you come on over here and have a
seat with me please you're looking far
too pretty to be a clown just science
what is your name my name's elissa well
that's not very funny
what is your clown name my clown name is
actually Alyssa - okay and how long have
you been a clown I've been clowning for
about six years
about six years how you kind of seem
unsure well you know who really knows
when they begin clowning because in the
end of the day I've been doing this it
does boy you know I'm talking about okay
and what are your specialty skills my
specialty skills are face painting okay
I haven't heard that before you must be
legit
so what type of clown are you I'm
definitely like a goofy clown
so I talking to southern accent yeah so
I'm like what do you like I don't like
to be honest I think that's kind of a
weird question what kind of clown are
you okay I'm doing the questioning
around here you can get back over here
in the line Bombur - come on over here
please have a seat I'll be getting back
to you later on I'm not really buying
what you're selling
hello sir who are you my name is Stanley
hi Stanley is that your clown name or is
that your given name it is my given name
and what is your clown name my clown
name is Zig are you making that up right
now
maybe and how long have you been
clowning I'm actually fairly new at it
so I would say maybe just one or two
years and what is your favorite type of
clown food David took a clown food Wow
they're gonna mess up the food I would
say just not going that good Kate cake
okay sounds like you just decided that
just a second ago and what color hair do
you have I tried to keep it just with
like a red wig of sorts okay and what
color is your lip my lips I keep it the
same
actually okay do you actually wear a
clown makeup at all keep it fairly
minimal I don't try to go too extreme
with it and what are your specialty
skills I stick with balloons yeah you
stick with balloons okay and what do you
like to do with pies pies I like you
know okay that'll be enough you come
over here in the line please thank you
very much I'm gonna be marking that down
just like you know okay uh let's switch
it up a bit you start right over here
come on over here and sit down
who are you my given name is David I
didn't ask your given name that's what
you wanted though
okay trying to read my mind I see what
is your full-time job professional Wow
what is your part-time job part-time huh
what is your hobby deciding better ways
to clown mm what type of clown are you
I'd consider myself an entertaining
clown the type that likes to sometimes
break down to song dance
I might spray you with water if you
don't laugh at my dance it just kind of
depends on the day what is your style my
style is traditional with a bit of flair
if I'm dealing with kids that are a
little bit more futuristic I'll I'll go
classic red nose white outline around
the lip you know okay I think that's
gonna wrap up the pushing for your that
I've got for you right now sir I can
overturn back over the line up please
you miss come on over here and sit down
please
who are you Daniella is my birthday and
what is your clown name boo-boo and why
are you shaking just a little shaky
better why are you wearing so many polka
dots cuz you know it's my day off the
job obviously when I'm on the job I wear
stripes never polka dots by off-the-job
polka dots okay and what is your
favorite circus snack circus snack
definitely jelly beans
okay next come on over here and join me
please oh I love the bike shorts did you
buy care I could have I could have tried
to unicycle but I'd fall right off and
what about mini bikes no no bikes for me
no bikes only trikes that's how I roll
I think it's funny and I think the kids
like it when they see that you can't
adult like an adult you're right they do
like that okay it starts so hard
what is your clown name my clown name is
Bing bong
after Bing bong and inside out because I
love that movie and I loved Bing bong
let me notate original name how long
have you been a clown one year I'm
really new and is that why you haven't
figured out that these little nails are
terrifying it these are fun to me
because I kind of like scaring some kids
sometimes but these are actually for a
trip to Florida so I will be returning
to my smaller oval shape where I can
touch things and not scare so many
children how do you do your makeup with
those bananas listen listen you adopt
you use the pads of your fingers I can
wipe my own after going to the bathroom
without scratching anything you learn
how to adapt like a text like a type in
what color polka dots are on your black
car because I'm not a grocery store
that's a grocery store gun what's that
grocery store trainer knows when you
have your comment come on you have this
beard or are you clean-shaven I actually
like to go a little bit more method so
I'll definitely be shaven to have my
entire face painted it you know this is
just from my offseason right now
you know deciding where the next journey
of my clown life's gonna go and you grow
out your hair for your clown look or do
you wear wear snot I have to keep it
this low so I can wear multiple wigs I
mean the color of the variation the
style I would like to know where you got
this one from I'm more talent well
that's just rude
mm-hmm curly hair straight hair curly
crimped actually I don't talk about
Dayton and what has been your most
significant experience of being a clown
juggling cats while standing on top of
an elephant definitely highlight Wow I
might just have to see that that's on
YouTube and what do you do when kids are
scared sometimes I'll go a little out of
character just for a second to you know
remind them that never mind
your new answer I do next question
please
hey let me just note that you are unable
to answer that question and what is your
biggest gig as a clown Madison Square
Garden do we work together alright so
for my next question what is the URL to
your personal clown website it is hmm so
you um hmm
it is www.thunderbird.edu
not fun very millennial they're
available I know and like $1.99 to get
it for the first year but then usually
like seventy dollars to review it the
second year Josiah what is your
signature special talent
if it's daring no is it silence
different types of balloon animals Oh
what is your most sophisticated balloon
animal I would say I stick to dogs but
different types of dogs so I can do
poodle I can try to do like a weenie dog
elongated and poodles and elongated
weenies are the only thing you can make
with balloon animals I can do larger
dogs like a German Shepherd Great Dane
how big we talking I guess it'd be hard
to do something life-size but let's say
that's what I'd use my hands it's the
secret ingredient in a pie
this cream keep it light it's just
whipped creams you don't you don't have
any like raw eggs or melting okay if you
had to guess something else what would
you guess what do you guess I know
you're wrong you're not the clown
professor
oh great I'm officially the clown
professor so I'll be doing the rest of
the questioning around here thank you
where did you receive your formal
clowning education a woman taught me how
to be a clown what kind of things can
you balance hot dogs or cream pies guys
in my own face that's what she said
have you ever been fired out of a cannon
no have you ever ridden a small pony no
have you ever been picked up by an
elephant's trunk
we have you ever stepped in elephant no
I'm definitely not a clown Oh can you
juggle I can juggle but it's not my
favorite thing to do so you can juggle
bugs juggle buds you said it not me
what is your entrance some kind of
question is that I can go at the same
one if I'm gonna do a party with
adolescents I'll try to go baby shark
you don't get them on my side earlier no
harder a little bit older then I'll just
go for whatever might be top 40 what
color is your clown costume it is
rainbow
of course and what color is your wig
also rainbow what color is your retainer
rubber retainer hmm almost gotcha
[Music]
well I am all done digging to the bottom
of my bucket of popcorn drilling these
fools I think the real clown is is
number five okay since it's not number
five
it must be number two well if it's not
five and it's not - it must be number
one Oh the least believable I do feel
good about being able to confuse him
enough so much so that he ended up
choosing me in the end because I mean
you know he fooled the problem I mean I
I'm surprised I confused him I guess he
was mostly confused by how can
convincing I was that he felt like I was
trying to hide something
so so being the official clown and not
being chosen first was kind of hurtful I
thought like us clowns could just smell
a woman put their yeah you know I felt
like he was just like he was like
judging members and then I started to
feel like am I even a clown like I don't
have a clown car and like I don't know
if I'm like at his level so I started to
really judge myself
[Music]